[Music]
and police criminal news
[ __ ] [ __ ] back
anyone submitted by teriyaki for Andy OH
but a big I don't want to know about
your sex fetishes
I know it's morning talk teriyaki
another kind of teriyaki never liked it
yeah Oakland is now recruiting ex-cons
for a commission that will oversee the
police department I believe you two said
that was a great idea I think it's a
great idea what is this exactly it's a
checks and balances so they're going to
have criminals double checking the
police department excess so that is
going to be the internal affairs yep for
the clean the streets
yep yeah so they're ambient county
county commissioners which is a
committee that's responsible for
overseeing
go yeah it's pretty crazy so that means
they did their time from doing the crime
and then they became better propose and
then now it's like okay I trust you now
and then they go hey police you're
supposed to be the good guy but don't be
the bad guy like who better to know what
criminals think that criminals
themselves yep I think there's somebody
bit off your guys idea I'm just saying
because you guys have said emulsifies
who's on JK news a watch just goes
what's wrong with you you drink some
water I choked on a [ __ ] ice cream
earlier thank you and it doesn't you
know you were fine the whole time
[Laughter]
everything about you with a whole bag
that did see their home is over oh man
oh man Joe yeah so the City of Oakland
posted on their website or would see
Commissioner saying quote must be in
Oakland resident lucky at least 18 years
old must be a felon formerly
incarcerated individuals encouraged to
apply oh [ __ ] what do they need a voice
like hey who's going to watch the cops
so this is a
9 member committee with two alternates
so they will be selected by the mayor
and by an 8 member panel civilians
selection panel it's a group of elected
officials that oversees any
administering that happens in the county
so police departments will fall under
that so then they would be overseeing
what they're doing in the department or
pretty much it so they're hiring ex-cons
to local police
so the ex-cons are going to be the
internal investigations they're not
going an internal investigation they're
just calling it coming uh Commissioner
Commissioner Gordon Oh mr. Gordon
they all have mustaches in a coat I know
everybody commissioner smiley
Commissioner smiley any well oh you need
my [ __ ] service these are what now
it's like the the head of the Oakland
Police Officers Association said that
recruiting ex-cons is extremely
distasteful ha you like what kind of
ex-cons - because I mean like you don't
want the top of the Commission and
person to be like an eight-time rapist
or like a pedophile or like you know I
think the position is the part that
throws people off a little bit maybe if
they were using on them on Commission
for like specific things right so there
have been a string of [ __ ] like like
burglaries or weather so we get like the
top dog that has done it that has
reformed his life and then we kind of
pick his brain for why this is happening
maybe might be a little bit different
story but they're having an ex-con over
see what cops are doing they're having
ex-cons police the police yeah and it
also sounds like it's just over a
complete city administration right so
that means like the fire department the
building department like if there are
people are adhering to like city
building codes to the janitorial waste
services to the parks and recreation is
that all of that they're in charge of
all that stuff well that was it
mentioned in the reporting they're just
focusing on the police department for
this specific committee so so this
position is basically seeing it that if
the cops are doing their job right or if
they're doing something wrong or pretty
much sick
we're seeing the different I'm not
exactly sure like to what extent it's
something that the police are against
the head of the Association with a net
business is tasteful but this measure so
this is a voter approved measure that
passed that's what the people want
yes they're saying that the people want
this to happen I feel like it's going to
turn out either really really really
good or really [ __ ] because it's
either going to be you have a completely
reformed incarcerated guy that really
wants to help clean up the police
department so there's no corruption and
all that or you're going to have a guy
that still in the criminal mindset and
now he's going to go to the cops and
he's going to slowly start turning all
of them like yo I work for the Mexican
Mafia and we're trying to bring in a
load of this crap
wrong boy still you got to do with the
right voice your name is creeper creeper
so hey what's up paces so hail c'mere
[ __ ] officer Johnson so like my
master he's trying to like bring in a
delivery and you know expenses that it
so I was thinking like if we duct tape
close gains on the bottom of the SWAT
truck and then [ __ ] tape up the noses
of the dog so they can smell that [ __ ]
well I'll give you a million dollars
that is either gonna be that or that
there we go
it just didn't seem believable at first
that's why I didn't believe it but I
believe it now Oh complete is kind of
[ __ ] up though because I saw some
footage of when they had the Occupy
Oakland kind of stuff and they were
clearing out the parks they had you know
the tear gas just shooters this was the
shoot up in the air right they're just
shooting the protesters directly with
those tear gas things [ __ ] yeah people
getting [ __ ] why are you laughing
like a sears lobby like broken up I'm
sad for the like the human part of it is
[ __ ] up
the funny part of it for me is that
these cops are just doing it without any
type of guilt any type of like remorse
you don't get funny it'll give a [ __ ]
they're just like I'm gonna do what I
was still I think it's funny because you
know what the cops true intention are
you know like coffee they're so [ __ ]
like
action hungry that when they pull
someone over and that's been speeding
when they pull them out they never like
sir get on the floor [ __ ] [ __ ] you and
they like every [ __ ] salute they've
been burning I know I can't wait to use
my move like this is like a seven year
old like old man yeah have too much meds
and there's a nice driving kind of that
so I think like with that type of cop
action hungry energy you can see like
you're supposed to go to but he's like
[ __ ] that yeah like I want to copyright
people the laziest [ __ ] cop on earth I
probably a fire pretty quick you're the
reason why they started that doughnut
thing you had that cop that started that
trend probably huh cause I need take it
I would have gauged the situation see
how bad it is like let's say like these
kids are drinking outside either like yo
don't do it in front of me go over there
bro what are you doing man like a [ __ ]
chillin right here [ __ ] you dumb ass man
give it a little stupid I feel like
David was started you trying to be ice
cream he'd get rolling in this [ __ ]
doughnuts good I would kind of help you
kids out of [ __ ] all the time
you can't rob from this tight at this
time specifically because I'm patrolling
so can you do it when these officers are
doing it I'm trying to work right now
bro you see the desk job cop I've been
all the cops with my question because
it's like these known criminal code was
so bro I was like oh my like good dude
he just passed your patrol schedules are
like the head of the blocks go so I just
got my work schedule this week kid did
y'all know criminal activity though yep
please please no but back to this
measuring thing they're saying that part
of the measure was they were saying that
they were looking for people who had
experienced police contact and so
obviously if you're formerly
incarcerated you have a lot of
experience with police conduct and
potential misconduct as well so that's
why they like the voters felt or backers
of this measure really felt that it was
important to consider ex-cons because of
they have like the most experience with
I think the intentions are pretty cool
yeah because like you want to get
someone that's been on the receiving end
of police brutality or misconduct or
whatever so you have someone that can
specifically look out for that stuff or
else to us like we don't really know
what is I think the regular person that
hasn't seen that like you don't know if
it's normal or not like when I tell it
when I met like just regular because
white people of how it was being like
Asian and SUV back in late 90s early
2000s and how did you just pull you over
pull you out of the car make your kneel
on the concrete hands over your head
while your friends drive by like they're
like what it's because they can have a
normal conversation with the police
officer but as soon as I see a police
officer I immediately see a big swath on
face that's true I remember feeling that
yeah you just feel like all [ __ ] there's
a cop and then you start getting anxiety
and you're like they're going to pull me
over for no [ __ ] reason and like keep
me out of my car for two hours for
investigation
yeah they search your car you don't know
your rights back then oh my god daddy is
going to [ __ ] unplug my stereo
systems I mean my friends took 8 hours
if I can put together and they take
pictures of you and then write you down
and a roster of gangs sorry those cops
too at that time they were just waiting
I can't wait like rabbi ayzik can use
all the racist jokes I've been kind of
using a longer time get on the floor
chow mein waiting to say that get lo lo
mein oh [ __ ] I can check that was great
basic effective action so did they
this is a racist [ __ ] they would always
ask like oh you can't speak English they
were say [ __ ] like that yeah because if
they have to repeat themselves it would
say that joke I just had to me a couple
times and I wasn't even this is like
what it was simmering down to but they
still said that joke I think if I was
adult now that I'd be a lot more pissed
but also scared to shoot if you repairs
would you say I'm Korean
like that joke doesn't make any sense to
me Congo super snobby about any kimchi
stupid hey you guys want to stock any of
us we'll go ahead down to the
description box below and you can follow
us on Instagram and I'll
and stuff for more videos
[Music]